je voudrais vous faire entendre
maintenant un groupe vocal qui s'appelle
poo alors poo c'est un mot indien qui
qui désigne la réunion des la grande
réunion des tribus où raisonnent les G
les champs sacrés alors ça ça s'inscrit
un petit peu dans le retour des de la
des groupes vocaux on avait reçu ici les
polyphonies Corse ce sont leur le leurs
cousins non Corse il y a Pascal prez
Pierre Bertrand Amed muissi et Alain
chenvrière et ils reprennent un titre
Salvador qui s'appelle le lion est mort
ce
[Musique]
soir la jungle TER jungle le lion est
mort ce
soir
les homes
tranquendor le lion est mort ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui sages dans le village le lion est
mort ce soir
plus de rage plus de carnage le lion est
mort ce
soir
l'indomptable le
redoutable le lion est mort ce
soir viens ma belle viens ma gazelle le
lion est mort ce
[Applaudissements]
soir
om om om
Omm a
a a a
[Applaudissements]
dans la jungle terrible jungle le lion
est mort ce
soir
[Musique]